you
[Music]
could you live in a simulation I think
that is related first of all so the
question what we mean by a simulation if
the question is could we be living
inside of a computer program then my
answer would be of course yes it is the
only thing that we get with some
certainty from the outside world is
information and the only thing that we
find with certainty in this information
is regularity and for a system to
produce regularity and information that
is discernible differences that change
in a way that is somewhat not random and
somewhat predictable for this it needs
to compute so it's necessary and
sufficient for the universe whatever
else it does that it computes and you
cannot really know what else does so in
my view it's necessary and sufficient
that the universe is some kind of
computer and pretty literal sense by the
way we define computers and computer
science doesn't mean that we know what
kind of computational class the system
is in and there is I think a lot of
context in the ideas and physics what
kind of computational class universe
really is in what capabilities it has
what can compute and what it cannot
compute but still its computational in
some sense
the question of whether we are living in
a simulation is more related to
something more narrow that is is this
computer program that you're living in
intentionally created or is it just a
natural occurrence and of course you
cannot really know this because no
feature in the world clearly points at
the thing being a simulation in the
sense I don't see anything that would
convince me that we are in a simulation
but if it is one I don't think it's for
our benefit I don't think that all these
galaxies and stars and all the intricate
elementary particle structures that we
can observe in some sense and that are
not necessary for our experience as
primates on the planetary surface would
need to be painted on the telescopes and
microscopes by the simulator so I don't
think that these are smoke signals and
we look into the sky and we see these
zillions of galaxies I do think that
they if this is a simulation then there
would be an important feature of the
simulation which means the simulation is
not there to create us the simulation is
probably there to
explore some aspects of hypothetical
physics and we are just a random side
effector an artifact of that detected
evolution is possible in this universe
so we could emerge in it I think it's
very unlikely that we are in a
simulation because if I would build a
simulation of the universe I would make
a computer that it runs on irreversible
what that means is that the operations
that happen in that universe can delete
bits it means that a state that we
observe in the universe can have
multiple possible escapes that it comes
from and if you look at what we know
empirically in physics that doesn't seem
to be the case our universe seems to be
reversible and this means we cannot
really delete bit if you cannot delete
bits it means that everything that we
like irreversible you know you'd
stabilize your body temperature you
forget yesterday's body temperature in
your body it means that you have to do
these bits and sometimes all the things
that you're interested in life planets
stars computers organisms minds are
irreversible in some sense they all need
to delete bits to keep their structure
stable against the onslaught of the
substrate which is has it's different
logic and it's different direction that
it wants to go into so in sometimes you
get waste bits you need to put the so
these bits of out of your system and
this is what P is observers perceive as
increasing entropy these waste bits and
if you would be living in a simulation
like Minecraft in Minecraft you can bill
to apply two or more videos
that's because you don't have entropy so
minecraft minecraft' can delete bits it
can forget its previous state this
universe apparently cannot so the reason
why they cannot have nice things in this
universe by the Canon of curvature
mobile is where entropy is always
accumulating and it's always going to
get us at the end I people always have
to die living beings that's why life is
always temporary every self-stabilizing
system we only have finite lifespan in
this universe that would not be a
feature I would put into a simulation so
there is this argument that for instance
in our masks make that we can build game
consoles that create virtual worlds that
look a lot like simulations to us of
this universe there can be so realistic
that you cannot
we distinguish them and this argument is
to me that every civilization that has
sufficient technical capabilities is
going to build many of these game
consoles so the probability that when
you look around and you find itself in a
pretty realistic looking world that you
actually in the simulation is much
higher than the probability that you are
in based reality but I think what this
doesn't take into account is the level
of detail that you can achieve in such a
simulation it seems that our universe
has an amazing amount of detail and to
get this amount of detail in a subset of
this computer it's very hard because if
you build a computer here on this planet
it means you cannot simulate a big
universe in it you can only simulate
very very very small slow universe in it
so every universe that you stack into
another universe is going to have many
orders of magnitude less detail so I
think if you find yourself in a very
detailed universe that has many many
galaxies a much more detail than you
need to have intelligent life and
civilizations in it and so on is
unlikely going to going to be a
simulated universe created by a
civilization it's more likely that
explains reality
[Music]